bonsoir à tous comme chaque semaine
france info et l'ina vous offre un
voyage dans le temps à travers les
archives de la télévision pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité contemporaine
vous regardez l'inattendu et vous êtes
les bienvenus là monsieur bonsoir je
voudrais regarder la franche au fond des
yeux ligne j'aimerais beaucoup de jeunes
apprennent à tricoter d'accord là-dessus
à votre place je la ramène un peu moins
mais si vous ne réussissez pas ce qu'il
vous manque qu'une seule chose un tout
petit détail le confédéralisme à paris
de ce qui lui arrive à la beuze à mes
côtés
ludivine lopez et eric haldi journaliste
à la rédaction de l'ina bonjour à tous
les deux comme chaque semaine vous avez
sélectionné des sujets d'actualité qui
trouve un écho particulier lorsqu'on
observe la manière dont ces thèmes ont
été traités par le passé tarik
aujourd'hui vous nous parlez d'accent
jeudi à l'assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi doit être débattu sur
l'agglo tôt phobies et l'ags
l'autophobie qui est la discrimination
envers les accents alors un député du
groupe agir à l'assemblée voudrait
qu'elle soit punie 1 tout comme les
autres types de discrimination vous vous
en doutez les accents c'est sujet de
moquerie 1 depuis très longtemps on va
le voir dans une archive
ce sont des marseillais qui nous
explique son 2010 c'est le terroir c'est
le soleil c
c'est l'expression des gènes de notre
pays nous avions une prof en primaire
qui nous disait que l'accent provençal
c'était un accent d'une guerre il nous
obliger à parler avec les mêmes comme ça
l'accent 26 lorsque j'étais jeune
comédien et que j'ai ambitionnait dé
jouer des rôles importants
on m'a fait remarquer à maintes reprises
ce que mon fois ci je ne perdais pas cet
accent méridional
il était exclu pour moi d'envisager quoi
que ce soit d'autre que des petits rôles
et alors en plus c'était des rôles de
personnages ou des gendarmes
1 c'est grotesque voilà ces personnes de
87,6 j'ai voulu vous la montrer c'est
que comme ce comédien dans mon cas moi
je viens du sud ouest à de lourdes dans
les hautes-pyrénées
ça s'entend plus pourquoi et délinquance
à rien parce que justement nathanel
ludivine il ya une dizaine d'années en
école de journalisme on m'a dit que si
tu le veux bosser ailleurs qui
affrontera toulouse il va falloir perdre
cet axe en voilà un petit exemple de
l'autophobie si on veut merci beaucoup
tarik autre sujet dans l'actualité cette
semaine le lancement hier de la trente
sixième campagne des restos du coeur
une édition qui devrait être marqué par
une forte augmentation des bénéficiaires
bien sûr en raison de la crise sanitaire
difficile de parler des restos du coeur
sans penser à coluche et à cette archive
elle date de 1985 quand vous allez vas
l'avoir la voir c'était lors de la
première édition des restos du coeur
coluche et 5000 bénévoles
le vrai dans toute la france regardez ça
va les garçons
un peu froid c'est quoi ta télé
restaurants du coeur une première pas
une minute à perdre dans quelques heures
600 repas gratuits vont être distribués
à gennevilliers au nom de paris sous un
chapiteau un stock coluche la locomotive
du projet il est partout c'est l'abbé
pierre des années 80 maintenant tu veux
ça va cette catégorie de gens qui sont
des chômeurs qui ont une famille on doit
c'est pas des clochards qui il donne
alors combats ont fait une distribution
plutôt qu'un repas parce que bon venir
bouffe et là c'est un petit peu juin
dérangeant pour eux qu'une famille alors
que là tu viens faire tes courses pour
400 personnes tu rentres chez toi de ta
bouffe était pas obligé de dire aux
enfants
on me l'a donnée vous avez entendu
inconnu évoquait déjà cette notion de
nouveaux pauvres une notion plus que
jamais dans l'actualité
d'autant qu'il me semble que c'etait pas
vous ai perdu reste exactement c'était
juste pour un temps une saison et ça
fait 36 ans que ça dure voilà pour
l'actualité de cette semaine mais sinon
que s'est il passé le 25 novembre ces
dernières années c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé un 25 novembre
regardez bonjour bonsoir mesdames bon
sens mesdemoiselles messieurs bons soins
dans ces démissions 4300 journaux
télévisés huit jeux olympiques
quinze mariages des grands de ce monde
léon zitrone était une véritable
institution de la télévision française
c'est dans ce quartier intensément
vivant du vieux paris au bout de la rue
brise michonneau médiévale que le centre
beaubourg va être édifié ce sera le plus
grand centre culturel de france et
peut-être du monde
on ne va pas retourner à l'époque de la
bougie si on remet en cause la recherche
dans le nucléaire il ya 50 % des parents
qui disent que pour corriger leurs
enfants il donne une gifle 44% qui
préfèrent la fessée et 8% mais oui le
martinet la ceinture
ça fait très mal ou la badine mais dans
quelle usine irez vous travaillez et
quels seront les emplois pour vos
enfants
beaucoup se souviennent à deux pas de la
place pigalle les grandes heures du
cirque medrano plus de dompteur plus de
plone plus d'acrobates qui font frémir
la foule le cirque medrano est
maintenant livré à la pioche des
démolisseurs
une scène que l'on coiffe une coiffe que
l'on fait
de là à déduire que la catherinette est
une jeune fille qui se fait des cheveux
soit exagérée ce soir et demain
jamais le black friday n'avait occupé
une telle place dans l'actualité alors
que des dizaines de commerces non
essentiels se prépare à rouvrir
eh bien les sites de vente en ligne
amazon en tête ont surpris tout le monde
en acceptant de repousser d'une semaine
cet événement promotionnel un des temps
forts de l'année commerciale à l'an
passé tenez vous bien 60 millions de
transactions par cartes bancaires ont
été enregistrés en france
à ce moment là bref ce jour illustrent
parfaitement tarik notre consommation
notre surconsommation on parle presque
de frénésie
on peut parler de frénésie avant
d'analyser ce phénomène là on va le haut
constaté avec des images en france et
aux états unis alors d'abord les états
unis cette archive date de 2012 c'est
les mêmes celles chaque année dès la
nuit tombée les gens sont déjà là c'est
des foules
on se bouscule on s'insulte on se pousse
pourquoi parce qu'à l'intérieur il ya
des télés de l'électroménager toutes
sortes de produits jusqu'à -70% alors
aux états unis le black friday on le
fait en lui cf on le fait
il a lieu en tout cas depuis les années
70 ce nom en france seulement depuis
quelques années là encore on va voir des
images de 2017 des images où on voit
plus ou moins les mêmes scènes les mêmes
scènes qu'aux états unis on se retrouve
aussi dans une course carrément et cette
année forcément crise sanitaire oblige
on ne verra pas ses images souvent vers
le rayon télé d'ailleurs tu arrives dans
l'écho et à l'entrée des magasins comme
on vient de voir ne sont tout de même
pas arrivé en france avec le black
friday
non non il y avait les soldes par le
passé pour que les jt nous montre un peu
cette frénésie alors c'est un peu plus
calme et on va là constaté dans une
archive de 1965 une archive que j'adore
c'est alors que l'on voit se transformer
subitement la plus douce des créatures
en démon c'est l'agressivité des femmes
digresse qui se disputent la même poids
bien entendu tard et qu'on parle de
femmes tigres et des femmes qui grâce
qui se dispute à g les archives de 1965
on commence aussi à se poser des
questions assure un tel comportement est
notamment un auteur georges perec qui se
demandent pourquoi est ce qu'on a besoin
d'acheter autant de choses dans la
société que l'on appelle société de
consommation et sociale est consommé et
tout nous pousse à consommer la
publicité des étalages des vitrines une
certaine manière nous rendent fous nous
saoulent toutes ces choses de son acte
pour entretenir une espèce de frénésie
de vertige hypnose ou nous pousse à
acheter un vous l'avez entendu mais je
voulais vous faire écouter une autre
personne qui s'est aussi penché sur
cette question c'est françois de closets
qui a dédié un livre qui s'appelle le
bonheur en plus ils se demandent dans
une approche plutôt philosophique est ce
que tout ça nous rend heureux
on écoute ses réponses je crois que de
poursuivre le bonheur à travers
l'augmentation du confort et les biens
matériels
c'est une voix illusoire c'est une voix
illusoire et qui nous conduit maintenant
à des crises de plus en plus graves
une voix illusoire et en plus ça peut
être pathologique dans certains cas vous
savez comment ça s'appelle à tout hasard
comme ça non l'hogneau manille au lieu
manie donc c'est l'achat compulsif une
maladie qu'on connaît à peu près au new
man i et puis les années 60 est comme
notre excès par exemple l'alcool un des
moyens de lutter c'est d'en parler
d'ailleurs j'ai appris en regardant dans
les archives qu'il existait des réunions
de débiteurs anonyme alors le principe
vaut là c'est d'en parler en groupe et
des journalistes se sont à au moins
pendant dix ans par les achètent pas
voilà c'est sûr ils n'achètent pas et on
va voir à quoi ça ressemble une archive
de 1993
toutes ces personnes viennent aux
réunions des débiteurs anonyme pour agir
sur leur comportement pour se donner les
moyens d'endiguer leur endettement
chronique chose qu'ils n'ont jamais pu
réaliser seul dès que j'ai un problème
tout ça pour même pas un problème je
peux être amoureux et pita que je vais y
plaquer
un peu plus que j'ai pas forcément des
grandes sommes est plus que j'ai en fait
je vous ai fait du mal je trouve que
toute façon toute personne qui va la
réunion d'un programme est une personne
courageuse et du doubs qu'à l'époque il
n'y avait pas internet donc tarder
face à cette surconsommation existe
quand même des appels à la résistance
lui des appels à une consommation
raisonnée en tout cas de la part
d'associations de la part de militants
et là encore en regardant dans les
archives j'ai appris qu'il y avait une
initiative assez
asseyez-vous quand qui s'appelle le buy
nothing day journée sans achat qui ce
n'est pas un hasard a lieu en même temps
que le black friday et assez
paradoxalement c'est de cette journée
sans achat elles avaient déjà lieu dans
les années 90 en france à moux en 1999
dans les archives qu'on va voir près de
lyon prosternation d'une dizaine
d'adeptes de la non consommation devant
l'un des temples de la consommation
le centre commercial de saint priest et
c'est une bonne occasion d'interpeller
les consommateurs pensent pas qu'ils
sensibilisent devant le public un mois
des fêtes noël entre les fêtes de noël
la course aux cadeaux et à la grande
bouffe c'est justement pour ça que les
antilles consommation s'adresse
aujourd'hui aux consommateurs que nous
sommes presque tous là on avait du mal à
convaincre à l'époque voilà une journée
sans un chantier qui tombe plutôt mal et
qui n'a certainement pas convaincu les
dizaines de milliers de commerces non
essentiels qui sont restés fermés
durant ce mois de novembre la merci
beaucoup tariq
[Musique]
il ya quelques jours jonathan d'aval a
été condamné à 25 ans de prison pour le
meurtre de sa femme alexia une affaire
qui nous rappelle que plus de 100 femmes
meurent chaque année sous les coups de
leur conjoint bonsoir ernest ernestine
ronai merci d'être avec nous c'est
aujourd'hui la journée contre la
violence conjugale
un phénomène en forte augmentation
pendant le premier confinement alors
vous êtes la présidente de
l'observatoire des violences envers les
femmes de seine-saint-denis est ce que
vous constatez vous aussi dans votre
département
une recrudescence de violences au sein
des foyers oui il ya bien sûr quand on
est confiné à l'intérieur d'un foyer
surtout quand ces petits etc
on voudra bien sûr un risque de violence
accrue c'est évident et du coup on
s'énerve et cetera mais les hommes
violence autre chose les hommes violence
ce sont des hommes qui ont la volonté de
dominer de prendre le pouvoir sur leurs
compagnes et sur leurs enfants
d'ailleurs et ça c'est de la violence
conjugale et c'est très différent d'une
violence on va dire qui serait dû à des
circonstances particulières et pendant
le confinement
cette violence s'exprime en effet
davantage et nous avons davantage de
violence et en même temps ce qui est
important c'est que lorsque les femmes
appel au secours
le 17 police secours est bien la police
intervient se déplacent plus que
d'ordinaire et réagit et c'est ça qui
est intéressant
alors aujourd'hui en france les
violences conjugales font partie des
grandes causes nationales mais ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas ludivine
depuis quand parle-t-on de violence
conjugale à la télévision ce n'est pas
si vieux que ça les premiers reportages
qu'on trouve nous alina date des années
70 alors à l'époque à cette époque là je
le rappelle les violences conjugales
sont à bout voire normale dans la
société française seule une poignée de
féministes dénoncent fermement les
violences conjugales parfois leur action
était relayée dans les médias
vous allez le voir sur les archives qui
vont qui vont suivre cette manifestation
en 1976 une association strasbourgeoise
exposait en pleine rue un cercueil
couvert d'un drap noir entourés de
fleurs un acte fort à l'époque il y
avait aussi à l'époque déjà des
témoignages
oui il y en avait peu mais il y en avait
des témoignages encouragé par des
associations
en fait les associations encourager les
femmes battues à parler de leur
quotidien à la télévision c'était le cas
en 1976 cette femme vous allez le voir
accepté de témoigner à visage découvert
c'était exceptionnel
à l'époque dans un documentaire diffusé
à l'époque sur antenne 2 il m'a roué du
coup et moi je suis tombé par terre je
voulais protéger mon bébé et en même
temps j'ai eu vraiment découle très
grave et après par la suite chaunu dans
le dos puisque j'étais couché sur le
côté et un moment j'étais un peu
inconscient d'emma traîner dans la
chambre et puis
je voulais crier encore au secours mais
il m'a mis le point dans la bouche
et puis maintenu son loyer pour que les
moyens ne m'entende pas crié un
témoignage du rhin glaçant vous l'avez
entendu c'est l'un des premiers à la
télévision en quoi ces récits ont ils
été utile ernestine ronai en voyant ce
récit ce témoignage je pensais au
premier livre qui est paru en france sur
les violences conjugales qui s'appelle
cris moins fort les voisins vont
entendre et je trouve que ce titre est
très parlant et c'est exactement ce que
dit cette dame
vous avez parlé de femmes battues
effectivement à l'époque on ne parlait
que de femmes battues c'est à dire
toutes les violences psychologiques les
violences sexuelles dans le couple les
violences matériel ça on n'en parlait
pas on ne parlait que des violences
physiques et déjà c'était un des rares
et c'est très important je crois que à
la fois ce témoignage évidemment et
émouvant peut pas dire autre chose et en
même temps il nous dit quelque chose de
la façon dont on regarde et les femmes
victimes de violences il a fallu
attendre les années 2000 avec l' enquête
nationale sur les violences faites aux
femmes pour qu'on arrête de parler de
femme battue et qu'on parle de femmes
victimes de violence et c'est pas tout à
fait la même chose
voilà des témoignages en tout cas si on
a bien compris nécessaire pour faire
changer les moeurs d'ailleurs cette
évolution des mentalités
ludivine on la constate avec un exercice
que l'on aime bien dans l'inattendu
oui même s'il n'a pas valeur de sondage
un jeune prof je le précise
on l aime bien parce qu'il permet de
prendre le pouls en fait d'une époque
alors avec tarik à lyon est allé dans la
rue poser exactement la même question
que dans l'hymne de nos archives le même
micro trottoir en 1975 et en 2020 juste
avant la crise thani tard je le précise
moi je suis je trompé ma femme mais je
suis l'amour
c'est le message qu'a fait passer ma
femme ma femme ne m'a jamais battu non
plus d'ailleurs
et vous monsieur avez vous déjà battu
votre femme c'est presque insultant
comme question jamais ça ne me viendrait
même pas à l'esprit avec une rose un peu
malheureux et si je vous disais que moi
je bats ma femme et sa fille gentille et
puis amoureuse de moi alors à certaines
familles lors faut il faut leur faire
rentrer à coups de poing je suis un
grand romantique les femmes j'ai l'écart
et se gêner les bop
le but c'est quand même d'avoir une
relation d'égalité et justement aller de
l'avant tous ensemble à des femmes comme
sa part je sais pas par habitude
peut-être garder un calme est battu je
préfère que elle me charrient efface
tout et munichois m e étape même si elle
veut mais moi non je pourrais pas alors
vous l'avez vu un les discours sur les
violences conjugales a évolué en 45 ans
reste en 60 ans s'est fait un nom comme
rihanna j'accepterai tout à fait hier et
c'était hier et ça a quand même évolué
on le constate face caméra face caméra
j'insiste parce qu'une fois la caméra
éteinte
les propos de certains sont parfois
moins modérée et dans les faits plus de
deux cent mille femmes subissent encore
chaque année les violences physiques et
aux sexuelle de leur conjoint ou ex
conjoint
ernestine ronai est ce que ça vous
inquiète ou est-ce que ça vous rassure
ce micro trottoir je parle entre ce qui
se passait en 1975 est ce qu'on répond
aujourd'hui dans la rue heureusement que
on a beaucoup progressé on peut pas le
dire autrement en regardant ces deux
micro micro trottoir on voit bien qu'on
a beaucoup progressé dans les mentalités
c'est vrai on n'a pas encore gagné la
partie en même temps il faut se dire que
il ya encore beaucoup de choses à faire
vous le rappeliez une femme meurt tous
les deux jours sous les coups et sous
sous les coups de son de son mari
violent donc c'est énorme
donc on n'est pas encore arrivé au bout
mais on a progressé
c'est ce qu'il faut ce dire et quand je
regardais le reportage et que je voyais
une gifle c'est pas si grave
malheureusement encore aujourd'hui il y
en a qui pensent les hommes violents
c'est pas tous les hommes
vous avez fait un micro trottoir donc
c'est du tout venant mais les hommes et
la valeur de sondage sur douala les
hommes violents eux pensent qu'une gifle
c'est pas si grave qui pourrait faire
encore pire cassé le bras cassé le nez
voire tuer donc on voit bien que la
gifle est encore vécue comme n'étant pas
si grave
alors que nous savons que l'âge même la
jfp elle vient après beaucoup de
violence psychologique
tu es nul qui était qu'une merde etc une
conne etc qui sont des mots qui casse la
dame et qui lui font très mal et arrive
la jfp mais pas du tout au premier plan
elle arrive bien après de longues années
voire wii dont années de violences
psychologiques et c'est en regardant ça
c'est à ça que ça me faisait penser
alors je voudrais préciser vous êtes une
des pionnières la pionnière en france à
avoir porté ce combat
l'observatoire des violences faites aux
femmes de seine-saint-denis dont vous
êtes aujourd'hui la présidente a été
créé en 2002 il ya presque vingt ans
c'est le premier du genre en france
quels sont les outils dont vous disposez
justement pour lutter contre ce fléau
le premier outil ces partenariats c'est
à dire que tout seul jamais une personne
un professionnel peut tout faire pour
une dame qui est victime de violence et
donc le partenariat c'est la justice la
police sait les associations les
services sociaux aide sociale à
l'enfance etc
c'est ensemble qu'on arrive à aider une
dame donc ses premiers outils le
deuxième outil c'est que justement
ensemble on a créé des dispositifs qui
fonctionne alors c'est en seine saint
denis qu'on a inventé le téléphone grave
danger que j'avais vu en espagne et que
j'ai ramené en france et ce téléphone
grave danger est un outil très important
bien utilisé en france on a protégé près
de 1000 personnes
367 femmes victimes de violence en 11
ans et 574 enfants ça fait près de 1000
c'est énorme et beaucoup de victoires
et du coup c'est important parce qu'elle
n'a aucune qui a été tué donc pour nous
c'est très important
alors justement les débuts de la prise
en charge des femmes victimes de
violences
c'était aussi dans les années 70 oui
exactement déjà ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que dans les années 70 il
n'existait aucun centre d'hébergement
d'urgence pour les victimes
à cette époque les associations
réclamaient des subventions pour la
création d'un refuge
et c'est précisément ce combat qui va
être médiatisé regardez ces images nous
sommes en 1976 des militantes de
l'association sos femmes battues
occupait un château en région parisienne
un lieu promis à l'époque par françois
giroux la secrétaire d'état à la
condition féminine
cette action médiatique visait à alerter
les pouvoirs publics
on a beaucoup dit que veut la mesure où
nous avait donné à local manager vous
nous l'a dit elle même et puis on
apprend toujours
il y a urgence il y a urgence il ya 150
femmes qu'il faut loger
il y à des femmes qui arrivent et qui
sont vraiment des maudits moralement
psychiquement qui n'ont aucune formation
professionnelle ces femmes là il faut
justement que la maison leur permettent
de trouver un travail
se rééquilibrer alors après deux années
de deux années de combats acharnés
l'association obtient enfin l'ouverture
du premier refuge français en 1978 pas
dans un château mais vous le voyez dans
un local plus modestes à clichy au nord
de paris vous allez voir sur sur les
images c'est le centre flora tristan qui
existe toujours aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
il a déménagé qu'est ce que ça
représente et se refuse à l'efo à
l'époque
ernestine ronai pour les femmes battues
ça représente l idée qu il fallait
trouver un lieu pour qu'elle puisse être
en sécurité
normalement la maison c'est le lieu de
sécurité est là pour les femmes victimes
de violences et bien la maison c'est le
lieu maximum de l'insécurité et de
l'insécurité permanente et donc ce lieu
de protection finalement était un lieu
qui permettait de se poser deux
éventuels m'en faire des démarches
judiciaires et donc de reprendre son
souffle pour reprendre sa vie en main
parce que l'agresseur avait complètement
cassé la dame et du coup ça lui permet
de repartir si je peux dire dans la vie
et c'est ça le sens de ces refuges alors
se refuse c'est une première victoire à
l'époque pour les associations
mais les femmes battues attendent eux
aussi surtout un engagement significatif
des pouvoirs publics
oui et on va le voir on voit dans les
assiettes dans les archives c'est à la
fin des années 80 que les pouvoirs
publics vont réellement s'emparer de la
question des violences conjugales
en 1989 la première campagne nationale
d'information et lancé une campagne
marquée par ce spot télévisé le premier
du genre c'est parce que trop d'hommes
s'imaginent avoir tous les droits dans
leur foyer que près de 2 millions de
femmes sont battues régulièrement en
france
la violence conjugale comme toute autre
forme de violence est inacceptable
trois ans plus tard donc en 1992 l'état
soutenait la mise en place du premier
numéro national dédié aux victimes
l'ancêtre du 39 19 cet accompagnement
des pouvoirs publics ça a changé quoi
concrètement ernestine ronai c'est très
important parce que évidemment c'est les
moyens qui vont aller avec une campagne
télévisée
c'est très très très important parce que
ça permet d'informer les femmes
ça permet d'informer
les voisins les amis la famille c'est à
dire tout le monde au tout et vous savez
souvent les femmes disent je les ai vus
à la télévision que j'étais victime
c'est à dire que le rôle vraiment de la
télévision si je peux dire mais aussi de
la radio est très important des médias
d'une manière générale pour permettre
aux femmes de se dire ce que je vis ça
n'est pas normal et c'est inacceptable
et cette campagne télévisée elle est
emblématique de sa cette première
campagne d'une prise de conscience
finalement de la société française qui a
quelque chose qui ne tourne pas rond
avec les violences faites aux femmes
c'est ça que ça dit et ça c'est très
important et on voit que ça produit
ensuite d'autres campagnes etc
et ça veut dire une politique publique
way qui va prendre en compte et en
charge la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes parce qu'après on a eu
des plans de lutte contre les violences
alors au fait que monter à ce qu est ce
que les promesses faites à l'issue du
grenelle des violences conjugales ont
été tenus il ya des promesses qui ont
été tenues d'autres pas dans les
promesses tenues on peut dire qu'il ya
des améliorations qui ont été apportées
la grande on ne vient de parler du
refuge le grand problème qui complique
vraiment continue en france c'est la
question d hébergement d hébergement
spécialisés avec un personnel formé
sécurisé non mixtes merci à vous et
ernestine ronai merci à ludivine pour
cette enquête
je rappelle les numéros d'urgence si
vous êtes victimes ou témoins de
violences conjugales
le 10 est bien sûr le 114 par sms et le
39 19
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
comme chaque semaine on se quitte avec
une pépite de l'ina la gadoue de pete eu
la carte clac clac clark et tu la claque
c'était en 1967 et oui elle est
accompagnée par le rappel de raymond
lefebvre
[Applaudissements]
on
du moins de septembre au moins douze
poudre et des bottes de caoutchouc pour
patauger dans la gadoue la gadoue la
gadoue la gadoue
la veille
une goutte d'eau matthew lynn dans le
dos nous pataugeons dans la gadoue la
gadoue la gadoue
[Musique]
voilà la gadoue que fredonner il ya
quelques instants avec à nos côtés merci
à vous on se retrouve mercredi prochain
21h sur le canal 27 bonne semaine
[Musique]